hello everyone and welcome to the 2018
World Chess Championship match between
Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano Caruana
for those of you who are just tuning in
to the championship or perhaps new to
this channel nine previous games have
been wrong it is a pretty long drawing
streak but it's not that the games are
boring or anything
it's simply both players are fighting on
very equal grounds and they are both
extremely precise in the moves they make
so this is game 10 if you remember in
game 8 where Kerwin also had the white
pieces he prepared a very nasty surprise
against cousins the last part variation
of the Sicilian that included a very
nice b4 advance of the pawn
grigory operon also used that at some
points to beat Boris Gelfand Caruana
improved on that game but still a very
rare line that Carson was prepared for
but not all that much here of course
Carson is definitely preparing the
expecting deadline so it's very
interesting what he prepared for it
before we check out the actual game I do
have a short announcement if you
remember a month ago or maybe two months
ago I told you that a an artist from
Chile who she made a song about
capablanca about one of his games and
that you should check out her song and
try to figure out which game she was
talking about and there was a bit of a
blunder by me because the the song was
actually about her own game and she was
just talking about Capablanca in that
game but now she released another song
it's called isolated pawn so also chess
related the first thing you'll see in
the description below is a link to her
song and in that song she actually sings
about a very famous game between two
very famous chess players so if you feel
like it do check it out it's done in
cleats the the song on her channel and
try and figure out the game for those of
you who watch my videos up until the
last second I will also include her
invitation at the end of this video so
before we dive into the game we do have
a couple of very nice photos also
compliments of Nikki Riga so let's check
it out here is Magnus cross and arriving
at the table you can see that Caruana is
still not here so perhaps taking the
fisher approach maybe maybe
for game it's very hard to say or Magnus
was just very early also we have a very
nice photo of the actual handshake when
Caruana
arrived so you can see that Clausen is
trying to get up but he wasn't just in
time so it's a perhaps a semi semi
diagonal handshake and also notice that
there is no eye contact whatsoever
both of them are just staring at nothing
so seems to be a very important maneuver
not not to be at all at you know
friendly terms with your opponent also
here is a very nice photo of Carlson he
seems to be you know fed up with Niki
taking photos of him so he's just like
you know beat it and also here we have a
very nice photo of Carmona who is
obviously of a similar mind as there are
so many photos of them or there are of
high quality and they have to really
come prepared for that also here we have
a very nice photo of this gentleman
making the first thing for Fabiano's
tall so as a photo challenge we can
guess who this person is making the
first move or Fabiano and for last here
is a very nice photo of the handshake
before the actual game starts again you
can see there is no eye contact and well
as quran i mentioned in one of the
interviews after the game he really
barely even looks at Magnus during the
game so that being said let's check out
what happened in this game Khurana has
the white pieces and he opens with E for
much like in game 8 karwa cross and
replies with c5 so the Sicilian defense
is on the board Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and e4 so the open Sicilian is on the
board
C captures Knight captures Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and E 5 exact same order of
moves that was played in game 8 Knight B
2 B 5 and now D 6 so the Alaska
variation is on the board Knight to d5
Knight captures pawn captures and now
Knights to be a the most frequent
frequently played move in this position
and here we already mentioned this
during game 8 in the past c4 was the
main idea here now a4 is the line pretty
much everyone plays here Bishop to e7
Carlsen continues in the
in fashion that he played game eight we
have Bishop to e2 and now comes castles
my cousin qur'anic also castles we have
Knight to d7 and here if you remember
well there are a lot of moves possible
here a5 is definitely possible here
immediately retreating with the Knight
to c3 is possible the move Caruana
played in game 8th is brush up to d2
where he prepares the Bishop to guard
the pawn and after the knight is
attacked and then I can actually come to
a 3 and the pond will already be
protected on a5 but here it's actually
Cara wanna who deviates again from the
game because he goes for the immediate
well not F I was the move played by
cousin in in gaming but here before is
the move Carmona prepared for this game
so he doesn't go for Bishop to d2 at all
but rather goes for this very early
Queen set expansion and Carson was very
shaken by this he started spending a lot
of time again as he didn't really take
this move into consideration when he was
preparing and looking for improvements
so any improvements he may have found on
game 8 were no longer viable after
Caruana makes this 12th move that is b4
so here after some 12 minutes across and
continues with a 6
we have Knight back to a3 and now cross
and continues with a 5 which seems to be
a bit odd because okay you can maybe
play a 5 immediately but not really yes
then then you allow the nice to stay on
b5 and now by playing a six-night moves
and really now going a 5 now bringing
the knight back to such an active square
like defy would be not all that great
here you can simply capture opponent
okay you will most likely win the pawn
back who after Bishop to d2 but after
Knight c5 Bishop captures 96 you are
perhaps allowing black too much activity
so after a 5 we have a big captures on
a5 and now comes Luke captures on a
five-night the C for forcing Carlson's
rook to move back
we have rook 288 and now comes Bishop to
e3 again using similar ideas like in
game 8 you want to push this point 2 8 5
and create a very nice outpost unbe 6 4
for your pieces and perhaps keep this
rook on
eight undeveloped for a very long time
and here
Carlson actually decides again to go for
this f5 move he could could have gone
for something like B six but then look
to be one is actually a very powerful
idea after rook captures on a four you
can go tonight capture some b6 and now
you will not be able to capture on b6
because of Bishop captures attacking the
Queen and after the Queen moves Bishop
to b5 losing the exchange as now both
the Queen and the rook are under attack
so what you could do after Knight
capture some b6 you could play rook a
three but still your rook would be
forced to run around the board and well
that's just too much and now you have to
capture it with the night because Bishop
to b6 is a threat you have to capture
with the Queen and now after something
like f3 black is most likely alright but
you know it's for something you're
unprepared it definitely don't want to
dance around the board and especially if
you're already out of the book and move
12 so we have F 5 by Carlsen and now
comes a 5 by Corwin s planned and here
across and pushes f4 a lot of people
were saying that maybe this early
advance is a bit too early but says they
actually agrees with Carlson's
assessment of f4 and here we have Bishop
to b6 if you play a move without a tempo
like this comes with an attack on the
Queen if you play something slow like
Bishop to d2 then even if or as possible
and now you're already controlling a lot
of squares here it's hard to say whether
this would work or not but there's no
need to allow it so Khurana goes Bishop
to b6 he attacks Carlson's Queen and now
you have Queen to e it also possible is
Knight capture some b6 but it's not not
at all great because after Knight
captures your rook is under attack and
after you move the rook now comes the
Bishop to g4 and after Bishop captures
Queen captures you have this very strong
night on b6 your look is terrible on a7
and the queen is very strong here
controlling this very important east 6
square so it's a bit too much - off to
our white to have so after attacking
Carlson's Queen with Bishop to b6
cousin goes Queen to e8 and now after
spending some 17 minutes here Caruana
definitely had to figure out a lot of
ideas one of them was Bishop to c7 do
you immediately go for this d6 pawn but
then cousin can simply defended with
Queen to g6 other ideas involved
something like Bishop to h5 attacking
the Queen because the Queen has really
has no retreat squares so here you would
have to weaken your King battling g6 and
then after weiter retreats back you
would basically waste a move here and
back with the bishop but at least you
would prevent black from playing Queen
to g6 so the Queen will be pretty poorly
placed on on e8 and also you've weakened
the blacks King side a bit but is it
really worth it to Tempe it's again hard
to say won a very nice move but it's a
move suggested by a computer is actually
rook to e1 you're simply waiting for
black to play Queen to g6 and as black
really has no better moves after Queen
to g6 and now you will play Bishop to d3
develop this bishop with an attack
against the Queen and after Queen to g5
play f3 prevent any advancement of
course and spawns but still even though
Corona most likely considered this it's
it's a hard decision to make I mean
you're also weakening your King side and
you're not really you can't really claim
that you're better this rook can come
into the game the Queen can also
threaten all sorts of nasty ideas on the
King side so with 17 minutes of
considering corona plays rook to a3 and
it's a very nice move the rook will most
likely be able to come help out with the
defense of the 3rd rank and perhaps if
maybe even attack against Carlson's King
comes then perhaps the rope will also be
able to help out with that here we have
Queen to g6 cross and simply brings the
Queen into the game but he had to decide
whether he wants to start a gang side
attack which rook to f6 maybe bring the
rook over to h6 and start an attack but
then you would have to make some
difference worse for your queen you
would have to bring the Queen to f8
Queen to f6 again and then maybe Queen
to h4
he decided if Queen to g6 is just better
and
quicker and here we have Bishop to c7 a
Caruana now goes for the d6 pawn and
there is a lot a lot of pressure against
it now also possible ideas were again
rook to b3 and the rook to e1 rook to e1
it's definitely an important move that
you'll see will be an idea for the rest
of the game because you do want to play
rook e1 and bring this Bishop to f1 to
help out with the protection of the g2
square and the h3 if needed but okay
Bishop the c7 was played a lot of
pressure is now against this d6 pawn for
now it is protected but you know the
White Queen can get attacked at any
point and here after some 17 minutes
cross in place
efore before he decides there was also a
very nice idea that included the move b5
but B 5 is not an easy move to make here
your knight is under attack
and you have to capture a capture some
b6 after you capture rook captures
Knight captures and now after your
Knight is an a3 only now you push efore
as you've taken care of pretty much
everything on the Queen side the knight
is somewhat displaced on a3 and only now
will you continue with your attack but
it's really not all that clear after
Bishop to h5 attacking Carlson's Queen
Queen moves now black will be able white
will be able to go quick into g4 and
here you will either trade Queen Tory
will capture Queen captures on d5 but
then comes c4 a very nice move after
Queen e5 now you get b7 this is the idea
because now you have to capture in the
night and d7 is unprotected Bishop
characters - Queen captures and now
after e3 we get this really really crazy
line where her where white is as you can
see up a whole night but black has this
very nice attack and it's very hard to
actually decide to go for this
so cross and instead of this immediate
b5 first place efore and now corona goes
King to h1 he doesn't want to allow his
King to be on this diagonal and also
perhaps rook to g1 will be an idea in
the future but now after some 15 minutes
of
duration Crossin display b5 he thinks
that now with the pond already on e4 it
will be a much better variation and
Caruana definitely does give this some
consideration as he should as it's
really a super complicated line I've
seen a lot of a live commentaries were
not a lot of people understood why a
captures on v6 was not good and in fact
Corona did play Knight to b6 but here I
will just show a line by says it because
it's simply too crazy and it leads to
all sorts of sorcery
if a captures then you get a rocket
captures on a3 and after Knight captures
on a3 then comes f3 of course you want
to start attacking you're threatening
checkmate on g2 Queen captures and g2 g
captures we have Knights to e5 now rook
to g1 attacks the Queen Queen to h6
and now comes Queen to c1 offering a
queen trade but now comes Queen to h5
black of course wants to avoid trading
Queens and he wants to check made the
White King Queen to e3 and now Knight
captures on f3 the threat is Queen
captures here and now if you capture
with the bishop then the Lupo capture
comes with an attack on the Queen and
which the two bishops and the rook and
the Queen black will have a very very
ugly attack so here white would have to
go something like rook to g2 to defend
eh to pawn but now comes rush up to h3
rook the g3 and now Bishop to g4 again
black is threatening checkmate Queen
captures on h2 and after white defends
once again now comes Bush up to g5
attacking White Queen Queen captures and
now comes rope the d8 Queen captures and
now rook captures on e2 and now you
cannot capture the Queen because you're
getting checkmate it robs you one row
captures and you one will be checkmate
and if you don't capture the Queen if
you go for Queen to see it check with
the idea of promoting your own pawn then
you get rook e8
now there is no checkmater but now b7
and after Bishop 38 and now there is
again a threat of rook to e1 checkmate
will follow after Ruby g1 is blocked
with Bishop to a5 preventing rook to e1
but now Queen h6 preparing a queen to c1
queen g4 now rook to g1 will be able to
block but still Queen c1 check
blocks night captures and now brush up
today to a very important move Queen has
to capture and now comes b8 bringing
another queen into the game nice to h3
preparing rook to e1 but now Queen te
six check rook captures and now an
in-between move Queen captures and e8
with check King here now pawn captures
with check King moves and here you would
have this position where black is black
is just better because why white does
have a passed pawn and almost ready to
complete a seven but his knight on a
three is a bit misplaced and you don't
really have the option of playing this
because you're just getting checkmated
by black Queen here and then after this
you're what the white is checkmate it so
here black white wouldn't really have
any good ideas Kings you two would have
to be played and then after Knight
captures black will simply continue the
King hunt and the most likely win this
game so this is a truly crazy line after
that Carlsen started would be five but
Corona managed to avoid it he did not go
for a capture some b6 but still it's
like it's a like you know definitely if
this happened it would go straight into
the sorcery series nights the b6 was
played and here we have Knight captures
and b6 Bishop captures and now before
was supposed to be played but Carson
actually decided to sacrifice a pawn and
he played Queen to g5 if you go b4 here
that saves your pawn then rook to be
three attacks the pawn and now Bishop to
f6 will be quite annoying threatening
Bishop to c3 and now if rook captures
you're still gonna play Bishop to c3 and
now you have to go rook to a4 to defend
d a5 pawn but still after better to d7
attacking the rook you will at some
point have to move the rook and now
white black will simply win back the
pawn and pretty much equalized
everything so here Carlsen decides he
doesn't want to go into this he decides
to sacrifice a pawn he plays Queen to g5
and this has only moved 23 so Khurana is
about to make his move 24 and he is
spending a lot of time Carlson also was
spending a lot of time but it's not an
easy decision can you actually capture
this point here here karana took some 18
minutes to decide on his next move
because well
or obviously you are gonna face a
terrible attack you have to calculate
what happens after III what happens
after after f3 what happens if Bishop
comes page 3 what happens if rook f6 row
page 6 and Queen h4 going for a
straight-out mating attack okay can
white stop this and do you in all this
madness have time to actually be a pawn
grabber but well let's just check a
couple of nicer ones for example if you
play f3 which is also a possibility then
you get III simply advancing the pawn
and now g3 this is what Khurana also
mentioned in the press conference that
was his idea
perhaps he he could play this but then
after captures rook to g1 simply as the
Queen is pinned the pawn is pinned and
the queen is on g5 after Queen moves you
will capture here and now after Bishop
to g5 defending the e3 pawn queen g1 and
now after Bishop here now comes this
very nice Bishop captures and e3 you
cannot capture the rook as the Queen
would be hanging on h6 so Bishop
captures the rook captures rook captures
on a5 and now we enter this rookie 7 the
threat is rook captures on g7 so now
rook to f7 captures captures we have
Queen to b6 and now roof to a-1 King g2
and here we have disposition that has
pretty much settled down and would most
likely result in some sort of a draw on
the other hand after Queen to g5 if
Caruana
grabbed the pawn he said that this was
most likely too greedy you don't want to
do this how do you defend against
checkmate
but if black actually goes for checkmate
would something like rook to f6 then you
have this rook to e1 this is a very
important move and after rook to g6 you
can go simply Bishop back to f1 so as I
mentioned this is a themed rook rook e1
with Bishop to f1 that's very important
f3
we have g3 and now your Bishop is
guarding this diagonal and it will be it
will be hard for black to break through
and he does have things to worry about
himself but you know it's a World Chess
Championship game you don't want to
allow such a such a brutal attack
for just one point so after Queen to g5
g3 was played by Caruana and here most
likely this game is a surprise to Magnus
as it did to everyone else because how
do you continue here Carlsen played b4
and it's most likely the way to go if
you play something like f3 and then a
bishop can capture on b5 and now what do
you play here if you try Queen to h5
with some ideas of Queen h3 followed by
checkmate
they will simply be met with rook e1 the
bishop can still come and defend with
the f1 if Queen comes Dan bishop to f1
and nothing good is happening here for
black on the other hand if you try
something like rook to f6 now to bring
the rook into the game then rook e1 and
then after Queen to have Queen to a5
Bishop will again come to f1 and again
black really doesn't have any ways of
pursuing this so after this g3 move we
have before as we mentioned and now
comes Luke to b3
again a lot of people were mentioning
that instead of rook to b3 you should
play the in-between G captures on f4
simply attack all since Queen and after
Queen captures rook to g3 which now
would give white a lot of a lot of room
here
but after Bishop to h4 of course black
will not allow you to calmly double
double rooks on the G file now comes
Queen to d4 a very nice move and now
after Bishop captures pawn captures the
Queen has to move Queen moves and now
rook captures on f8 rook a king captures
and now we have Queen captures on e4
but after Bishop to h3 it seems that
Carson assessed the position correctly
and Khurana both now black is simply up
the exchange even though white has two
very powerful bishops and the past ponen
already on a5 black would have the
advantage here
so after before we have looked to b3 not
going for this in-between move and
Bishop to h3 by Carlsen again if you try
f3 now which is a definitely a
possibility
Bishop can again come to b5 even though
now doesn't come with a capture rook to
f6 rook to e1 now after Queen to g4
going for mate
Bishop to f1
and after Luke to h6 again Bishop to e3
attacking the rook and after g5 black
will most likely have the upper hand
here but still there is no clear way of
of actually finding a decent plan here
for black so it's a not at all easy
thing to decide to do so instead of f3
first across and played Bishop to h3
attacking the rook we have roped the g1
roof to G 1 is better than rook to e1 if
you go rook to e1 then ideas like Bishop
to f6 the c3 will be possible where you
will either defend at this point
indirectly because this will come with a
double attack on the rooks but it's the
wrong g1 is just better and here after
some 15 minutes and minutes across and
played f3 and here across and had 15
minutes on the clock whereas Caruana had
18 so definitely both are really
draining their clock rush up to f1
Bishop captures and here we have Queen
captures it might seem a better idea to
capture with the rooks of the Queen can
keep an eye on the d5 pawn but then rook
to f5 will still just pick it up and
black will now even be better because
the rock on f1 is not really doing all
that much in the Queen will have to move
from the D file after Bishop captures an
f1 we have Queen captures an f1 Queen
captures on d5 and now rook captures
time before Queen 36 and now comes roof
to b5 rook the b5 is a super cool move
by Fabi everyone thought that he will
play c4 it simply prevent d5 because now
if you of course play d5 yes the ship
does attack the rook but there is the
in-between move that attacks the Queen
and now after Queen captures rook d4
will be very strong Queenie 6 if you
want to keep an eye on this pawn but now
simply Queen to be 1
what defends everything and now rook
captures will be a huge threat but on
the other hand if c4 then Bishop to g5
is a very strong move sorry instead of
if c4 was played then Bishop to g5 would
have been very strong but like Fabian
decided to do rock to b5 well protected
the g5 square so here if he actually
allowed
then the threat of III would be perhaps
somewhat and advantageous to black but
he decided to go rogue to b5 he decided
to keep an eye on the g5 square and here
cross and played Bishop to d8 you have
to decide whether you want to play this
or you want to go after the the C pawn
but even then the Queen will come to b1
and everything will be fine
you will even just improve the position
of the White Queen so first Bishop to d8
we have Queen to e1 not allowing this
pond to ever to come to e3 Caruana will
definitely put his Queen Eaters to e3 or
d4 to control this very important
diagonal as as much as he can
Bishop captures we have a capture some
b6 and now rook a to b8 here we have
Queen to e3 as planned and now comes
Queen to c4 here also if you try
something like rook to f6 and you play
b7 this is just to show you that the
position is not without any danger for
example if something like Queen to h3 is
played and fabi's and careful play
something like Queen to a7 goes after
the rook then there is no need for
something like this because there is a
very nice tactic Queen captures on h2
King captures and rook to h6 will now be
checkmate because the rook is simply in
the way of the Kings that retreat square
and this point is covering g2 so now
after this roblox it will be a very nice
checkmate but ok after Queen e3 Quincy 4
we have looked back to be to defending
the b2 pawn and now comes rope to b7
here Carlson had three minutes and
Kirwan had 7 and they still had to make
6 more moves to reach time control loop
to d1 going after the d6 pawn and now
comes Queen to e2 a move across and
missed
Fabiano missed that really packs a lot
of poison to it because now well there's
a whole lot of danger here for example
if you play something like Queen to d4
then you get to this very unpleasant III
move and now there's really not all that
much you can do here you cannot capture
with the Queen because the rook would be
hanging and of course you don't want to
allow black to capture here and on the
other and on the other hand if pawn
captures and Queen to g2 will be
checkmate
so this is a one such poison and the
other one is actually even greater if
Queen to b3 check King moves and now c4
it seems that Caruana has now trapped
Carlson's Queen but this is the problem
and this is the trick crossing had in
mind
now comes Luke captures on b6 and now
white is lost now whatever you play
let's say rook captures here now you
first play pawn captures rook and now
you're also threatening to capture on d1
so after Queen a for you all so you
definitely want to keep an eye on that
rook on d1 now comes Luke to a6 a very
important move and after Queen moves
only now your capture
Queen captures and now after Luke
captures on f2 the two rooks against the
Queen are are so winning that it's
impossible to play this with white after
a white tries any move of course you
will protect against checkmate but then
after something like King g1 III is
coming and now after this
now everything pretty much results in
checkmate after Queen e3 you will simply
play rook to e2 and now either the Queen
will move and then rook to e1 is
checkmate or Queen will block the a1
square but then rook e1 will be
checkmate
so Queen e2 a move that really packs a
lot of poison but Caruana responds
properly rook to e1 and now you really
don't have any options you have to trade
Queen so we have Queen captures rook
captures and now d5 we have h4 by
Caruana the best move giving your King
some breathing space you don't want to
allow any back rank weaknesses as the G
2 square is covered so ideas like rook a
71 will also be possible so first h4
look to see it by Carlsen the trying to
put pressure against the c2 pawn and now
comes rope to a3 a very nice defense
Corona found we have kink to f7 and now
comes move number 40 King to h2 Caruana
has reached on control and the cost and
by playing King to e6 also reaches time
control we have g4 by Caruana rook the
c6 with a double attack against the b6
pawn and now comes Luke to a6
a better idea then this rook the beat
removed where White's rooks will be very
passive and then after h6 the blacks
position which will just be very nice
here after loop to a6
I think I've heard Gary mentioned that
this is although it seems like a more
passive square white always keeps the
option of playing this rook to a7 so
King to e5 by cross and now you don't
want to allow this game to come to a 4
so King to g3 we have H 6 H 5 and now
here cross and spent 13 minutes because
he has to decide what to do here he can
either play g5 which will pretty much
draw by force but we can even show it
just a second for this video I even
prepared a glass of water
ah very nice so King d4 was played in
the game but Carson could have played g5
immediately but that would force a draw
after H captures rook captures rook the
b5 we have h5 and now rook at a 5 with a
double attack against the d5 pawn came
to f6 rook captures but now rook
captures and g4 came to h3 rook captures
and b6 and now rook captures on h5 and
now although it seems like a very strong
position for example I have to look to
g2 white King is really down in the
corner but you will never have time to
play something like Ruby g1 and rook h1
checkmate because the white will simply
not allow its rookie 6 check now you
can't move the King because you're gonna
lose the rook so you have to block it
and now after this exchange it's simply
two against two
a very drawn in game so across and
decided he is not interested in drawing
this just yet he decided to go adventure
mode with kinked d4 and here corona
pretty much not immediately because
there are no longer in time trouble
they've reached and control played rook
to be 5 and this move Carson says that
he missed because now well you're only
gonna run into trouble if you capture on
c2 then rook to a5 is coming and you
don't want to allow White's to capture
on d5 while your king is on d4 so here
one option would be to come King to c4
but this is again a line by sesay it
seems a very inhuman to come this close
into the action with your king and then
after after rook a to a5 rook captures
on b6 and then only
rook captures on d5 but still you don't
wanna you don't want your king all the
way here so instead across and play rook
to d6 and now we have rook to e4 check
King moves and now comes King he kinked
before defending the b6 pawn once again
King e6 now comes c4 pawn captures rook
captures rook captures and now rook
captures on e4 with check King to f7
rook to f5 check and here karana
here could have tried to play it
differently but he said that after
calculating everything out he decided
everything was a draw which is the
correct assessment ruku if I was played
rook to f6 captures captures and here
route King captures an f3 Caruana is up
upon but this is a theoretical draw and
Corona is more than more than convinced
that Carson is able to play this out to
do a draw meaning if someone was played
and after King to g3 on move 454 the
players agreed to a draw so there we
have it that was game 10 a very very
intense game that featured a lot of
possibilities and I don't think that
it's even possible to make a video about
this book as it features so many lines
so many crazy ideas you could easily
make like like a three-hour hour video
or write an entire book perhaps about
this game because it really has
everything so pray if you are new to
this match or new to this channel you
can see that even though the game ended
in a draw it was it was pure source to
redraw so and like a promise for those
of you who have come to the end of the
video we also have a video invitation
from Hoover herself to check out her
video and try to solve her challenge so
here it is it's it's a very short
invitation so I hope you enjoy it let's
check it out holder hi everyone I'm Hoda
a songwriter an artist from Chile I'm
also a chess lover and I'm in London
watching the chess world championship
and about to release my new chest music
video called isolated bone actually miss
Anna rule
is filming this video hello everyone the
isolated pawn video includes a chess
sequence inspired in a famous game can
you find out which is the game that
inspired this chest sequence you can
check out the video at my youtube
channel Hogan or at hua musica comm hope
you enjoy it so yeah there you have it
the link to her video will be the first
thing you will see in the description
below feel free to check out our
challenge best of luck to you I would
like to thank Antonio : ello Jersey lapa
Munna Munna does in Yahoo Glen Brock and
the norman stone lee or enormous storm
the third for a contribution to my
channel think a lot I really appreciate
it as usual you can check too in my
previous video so your think all for
watching and hopefully I will see you
soon with another interesting video but
yeah how do you like the match so far
and I mean what is your opinion of this
game is it pure source sorcery or what
but yeah thank you all and I will see
you soon